a former UFC fighter was hit by a car
and killed in Brazil's at Brazil after
he got in an argument with a rideshare
driver who did turn out to be working
for uber at the time the the fighter got
out of the car got into an argument
according to the police reports the
driver stopped the car started driving
away but then turned around and ran this
guy down from behind and killed him yeah
I mean at first I thought I honestly
when I read the thing I thought UFC
fighter tried to fight a car which was
funny because you know when you're a
fighter like at the UFC level you know
the way that I am then you can you just
feel you can take on anything you know
and win but then when I found out the
driver trip away I waited till he had
his back turned and then drove as fast
as he could and killed him I thought
this is even better this is like I think
do you think if you were an uber driver
this would be your dream is to kill a
passenger I mean it's definitely the
best way to if you have to kill a UFC
fighter I think hitting them from behind
in a vehicle is probably the way to go
for sure for sure they're not they're
not prepared for the head right like
there doesn't matter how many rounds
you're doing mm-hmm you know you're not
coming back from yeah and you didn't he
didn't like hit the horn to try to get
him to turn around he just must have
turned off his headlights and just went
right at him which i think is i think
it's every uper drivers dream well he
never gotten out of an uber without just
backing away slowly so you you're in
fear sometimes when you get out that
maybe they'll pull this off every single
time I've been in an uber I've made them
enraged they the uber uber did make a
statement which I enjoyed which which
said they have let him go no longer not
just rating down to four stars
don't worry I don't know what do you
think he said to the uber driver you
know what I mean like they got into some
sort of argument and it was just it was
just verbal by the sound of it there was
no like altercation physically but he
got out of the car after some argument
in whatever he said apparently enraged
the uber driver and I've got to imagine
the
that the UFC fighter was like hey you
here Justin looks got a new special
dropping on the 30th it's called firing
in maternity wear I think it's me his
best one yet and the uber driver was
like I think thoughts and prayers is
unbeatable that no matter what he comes
out with it's not gonna be as good and
then it just escalates from there you
know that's worth killing a man over for
sure I mean is it worth it like I think
it's his own reward but but it doesn't
surprise me that someone died that day
what if like what if the last thing he
says he jumped out of the car was bet
you can't kill me do you think that do
you think I don't know just trying how
much would he bet like how much money
would you give an uber driver for trying
to kill you I mean the guy had a wife
and kids and you know not more Greg not
anymore
Danny Amendola went on a Instagram rant
over the weekend which Erica was of
course following closely because that's
her favorite NFL player and why why is
your favorite because of his temperament
with women must be no he's just really
hot he's not my favorite player and so
he got he broke up with this girl where
they broke up and then he found out she
was like making out with some dude
apparently videos from Coachella this
weekend or the the first weekend
posted where she was hanging out with
Zedd the DJ he's a Swedish DJ mm are we
supposed to know who that is yeah he has
like a couple of big songs like you know
we didn't you know we're too old no I
think there's nothing weaker than
talking trash on an axe and especially
publicly where you rant about it so we
thought it'd be fun to have Erica read
her favorite players a screed against
his ex it's quite long but Erica's voice
is melodious I believe there should be a
boundary by the way I think it's between
private life and social media
Olivia believes in fishbowl lifestyle
this fundamental difference was huge in
our relationship if you're my real
friend you know I'm a private my mother
brother father and nephew are closest to
me in this world and you don't see one
picture of them and that's for their
protection from those who criticize and
judge I believe in nailing
sure frames on the inside of my house to
remind the ones I love that I care
Olivia chooses and wants to be noticed
on the internet and in Hollywood to make
money where is he he nails picture
frames at the inside of his house and
he's bragging about this he's bragging
about that because those are somehow
more real than the Instagram photos he
doesn't like to be in public he's
private that's why he's posting
his all his thoughts about his
ex-girlfriend on Instagram but are there
people who'd nail picture frames the
outside of their house cuz they wanna
live in a fishbowl look what my family
looks like that was like the
pre-internet era of like Olivia culpa
would be like that back in the 70s you
would just be posting pictures of her at
the beach like on the outside of her
house yeah like it's it which was hard
for me to understand but I quickly had
to learn whereas the cost of Fame in
this world doesn't appeal to me I play
ball for one reason and that's respect
the only reason I'm writing this post is
because whether I liked it or not we
lived in the public eye just like any
other loving relationship we fought a
lot of the time it was my fault because
let's be honest I can be an idiot but
yup she up too and if you cross
me I'm a hard mf'er to deal with the
universe brought her and I together to
enjoy life love and learn we celebrated
that as often as we could and the sex
was crazy too
she gets everything he started the post
by saying now he's a private guy he's
only posting you know picture frames
inside his house and he's now gotten to
her being what like that fall and that
the sex was wild she gets so mad at me
for not posting her on social media but
I think the is sometimes fake
sometimes toxic but sometimes beautiful
and I felt like she had enough pictures
online anyway truth is I have a whole
cell phone of funny embarrassing sexy
pics IG would love to have how was that
a threat it seems like it seems like a
brag not sure what's in the future but
the only thing I care about care about
is her happiness and if that's Dancing
with scrawny little so be it
and he also spelled scrawny scr
oh so dumb yeah I mean that took some
wild twists and turns I never that
entire thing a very private person
like a horse my girl from was great but
I thought she had enough pictures online
that she didn't need anymore
even though I've got pictures that are
crazy if you guys saw my pictures oh my
god I have a billion dollars because
people would pay to see these pictures
but you know how you know me
I'm a nail of the frame to the inside of
my house kind of guy I love my cousin
forever I wish you nothing but happiness
and I hope this post helps is he still
your favorite player no no I mean I
think one thing we learned from this
interaction or these posts cuz there
were more was that Danny Amendola
not that bright oh my God he's so dumb
you see the most embarrassing Patriot in
history I mean he's now a Detroit
lawyers close but he was once can you
think of any Patriots players that are
been more embarrassing no me too but
that's not embarrassing you don't think
so Danny Amendola also published two
apologies
I think deleted both of them or deleted
at least one of them well first of all
if your no offense miss - miss universe
but if you were dating him for this long
off and on like you know how Donny is
sure know so if you see that like it's
probably like ah like he saw me was
said I think if you're a former Miss
Universe then you're so smart
that everyone seems stupid you know what
I mean that it's like it's almost
impossible to find someone at your level
intellectually but as long as they
like champs and she and she takes it
into consideration to start nailing
picture frames on the inside of her
house I assume right now she lives in a
tree house and it's filled with mementos
on the outside he deleted that that
apology - but not before Julian Edelman
his former teammate responded step away
from the Instagram man that's that's bad
for the ladies he's available that would
not really change you would still get
with it Damon though
be real yeah I mean he's dumb but I mean
how dumb would someone have to be
podcast listeners can't see your facial
expression dumb but I mean they can
figure it out like if someone was like I
don't need to go to dinner with him
someone's super hot but illiterate like
literally illiterate would you still
have sleep with them maybe what would
what if like what would they have what
would they have to do for them to be too
dumb no I could never I can never sleep
with an illiterate person yeah like if
you can't read get out of here I mean
it's hard from what about like kill four
separate people in like two different
instances and leave gum at the scene of
the crime
definitely wouldn't have you seen mmm
now I think you I think you missed your
opportunity there
[Music]
you